ever since the insurrection at the
capitol there's been a wave of
resignations
from people that work for donald trump
now
a lot of people say it's too little too
late and that most these people are just
trying to salvage their reputations
for future employment well i figured
we'd talk to one of those people
and find out exactly why he resigned
please welcome
trump staffer ken wheatley hi conan um
it's
actually former trump staffer okay of
course ken tell us
when did you resign about 10 minutes ago
10 minutes ago i just can't in good
faith be a part of this anymore
yeah all right well ken it's it's past
it's past 11
p.m there's less than one hour left in
trump's term
exactly and i can't sit idly by and
support this kind of behavior for the
next
53 minutes i mean the fact is his
conduct of late has been
unconscionable all right well i agree he
provoked his supporters to storm the
capital
it's pretty bad you know no i'm i'm
talking about the fact that today he
didn't even stop by my office to say
goodbye
he's finally crossed the line and i'm
done
didn't say goodbye what about the dozens
of time he's abused executive power
what about no last day cake in the
conference room huh i can't be part of
such a callous administration
by the way if any future employers are
watching you're looking at a man whose
dignity won't be compromised
plus i know microsoft word and excel all
right that that is exactly what i mean
it just seems to me like you're
resigning on a technicality
to improve your future employment
prospects
wait what's that my biggest weakness i
guess sometimes i focus too much on the
details i mean
whether it's a misplaced comma or
picking the right frame for my degree in
electrical engineering
stop it just stop it stop it you've
worked for trump for four years
that is on you look i had my doubts
about trump for some time
yes i agreed and supported all his
policies but i was being sarcastic
also i'm known as the funny one in my
habitat for humanity meetings in case
there's any headhunters out there you
know what that's it i hope you never
find another job
i think i'll land on my feet
i'm sorry what's with the mustache well
you can't
indict someone you can't find say hello
to lifelong democrat
dirk thunderhorse all right whatever uh
dirk thunder horse i guess uh
i'm a birdie bro oh whatever awful awful
person